we are now ready to find the most likely
hidden paths
in an hmm and its correspond to the
following decoding problems that ask us
to find the optimal hidden path the
input is an emitted string
and an hmm defined by four object
alphabet the set of states the matrix of
transition probabilities
and the matrix of emission probabilities
and the output
is a hidden path pi that maximizes the
probability
of x and pi
uh probability of x pi as we saw
equal to the product of probability of x
given pi multiplied by probability of pi
and it is a product of n
term each term being the product of
emission probability and transition
probability
as described at the slide to solve the
decoding problem we will try to build a
manhattan graph
in such a way that every path in this
graph
will correspond to a hidden pass in the
hmm
and vice versa every hidden path in the
hmm will correspond to a path
in the built manhattan for the
coin flipping hmm with this hmm diagram
we will construct manhattan consisting
of two rows
and n columns where n is the number of
emitted symbols
in this case we will also add source and
sink node to the beginning
and to the end of the resulting directed
acyclic graph
and for the hmm that
emitted the string of symbols f b b b
f f we will construct the following
paths through the manhattan right here
and you see that for every string of
emitted symbols
we can construct the path in the
corresponding manhattan
for a little bit more complex hmm
consisting of three states
our manhattan will be built of three
rows and end columns generally if we
have an hmm with this
k states there will be k rows
in this manhattan as before we will add
start
and end states and note that
in difference from the alignment
manhattan when we had
just three directions from every node
in the decoding manhattan we had many
directions
anything that goes to the east
works in this newly built manhattan
we now need to define the weights of
edges in the newly built manhattan graph
for an hmm let's consider an edge
then starts in column i minus y
in state l and connects it to the node
corresponding
to state k in the column i
we will refer to this edge as
l k i minus 1.
now this edge corresponds to
transitioning from
state l to state k with probability
transition l k and it also corresponds
to emitting the symbol
x i from the state k and therefore
we define the weight of this
edge as weight l
k i minus pi carries and it equal to the
product of uh emission probability
uh of uh emitting symbol x
i from state k multiplied by transition
probability
from state l to state k
let's see how would we assign
edge weight for the crude casino in this
case
as before weight of the h
l k i minus 1 equal to the product of
the corresponding
emission and transition probability what
about this
edge so the weight of this voltage
from state b to state b are equal
to emission probability of emitting
symbol h from state b multiplied by
transition probability of moving from b
to b which is 0.75
multiplied by 0.9 and we will continue
further with assigning the probability
of all edges in a similar fashion
and afterwards we will construct
a graph in which product weight
of a hidden path will be
simply equal to the product of weights
of individual edges as shown on this
slide
for example the uh product weight of
this path will be simply
uh equal to probability of
xp therefore we constructed
a graph in which product weight of every
path
equal to probability of x pi
exactly what we are interested in and
therefore
the computing of probability of x pi and
finding hidden path pi
corresponding to maximizing probability
x pi
is simply finding a path with his
maximum product rate